you know they look like the lobby of
bulldogs
was this the same guy who gave you the
lokai braces yo man
charles what are you doing how did you
wait time out how did you exchange
shirts we just took in a hotel lobby if
we were in the bar
we were in the car we were drunk in the
bar we just switched you
obviously you don't have a t-shirt
underneath that no i didn't have a
t-shirt on
charles do you know this guy i don't
know him oh my god hold on
hold on what did he come up and just say
i want your i want your shirt or did you
say i want your shirt i'm not gonna ask
another dude for his shirt stop that
already
you put another man's shirt on that you
didn't know well we swapped shirts
great time out except let's see let me
just say here see this one reason i hate
working here
y'all took some so pure and innocent you
know about that just like
no counters the less like the low-carb
bracing
it was so clean and pure and innocent
y'all made it so bad ernie can i ask a
question oh please
hi okay i whoa
how did it get to a point where he felt
comfortable enough to
say to you hey let's change shirts
in the middle of the bar and take a
picture well he just
and you don't know him what
comfortability did y'all get if i
remember correctly
we just he was a nice guy we started
talking oh my god
i would really would love to have a
charles barkley shirt and we switched
shirts
and why you got your hand on your hip
like that
what are you talking about see y'all be
making
something that's so sweet oh kitty hey
something
i couldn't get past the fact that he
changed shirts so maybe i did
i gotta maybe look at the picture hey
just the thought of you guys in the bar
at a high class
uh hotel like that uh taking your shirts
off
and and then swapping them well it was a
nice moment
i guess it was yeah y'all just haters
did y'all anything else shirt back
oh and now there's charles with the uh
with the velvet
uh and they're with d wade and
with reggie miller